russian installed authorities in
southern ukraine are delaying a
referendum on whether hassan should
become part of russia officials cited
the security situation a rare
acknowledgement of the ukrainian
counter-offensive there kiev says it's
making progress and has taken several
settlements in southern and eastern
ukraine
this video obtained by reuters appears
to show soldiers raising ukrainian flag
in one small town in ghanson region
kiev began its long-awaited
counter-attack last week
for more let's speak to dw correspondent
nick conley he's in kiev nick the
occupying authorities in hassan say they
cannot hold their plan extension uh
annexation referendum rather for
security reasons is this a sign nick
that ukrainian forces are making headway
in their efforts to retake hassan
i think it definitely is um we didn't
really ever have a concrete date but we
did understand they wanted to hold this
referendum which really reminds us of
what russia uh russia's playbook was in
crimea back in 2014 around kind of the
middle of this month of september um i
don't think they are going to give up on
trying to do that but certainly for now
that is not on the cards it's just too
hot right now in her son
seemingly hourly uh shelling of russian
positions there by ukraine lots of video
on social media it's very difficult to
verify
of attacks on russian weapons depots but
also on the infrastructure on the
bridges across the nipro river i think
it's important to remember that this is
a very localized offensive this is just
about the west bank of the nipro river
there's a small section of territory
there that russia controls it's easy for
ukraine to isolate and cut off from
supply this is not bigger this is not
about the much bigger part of southern
ukraine that is still
fairly comfortably in russian hands but
certainly this is a blow and we have
seen been seeing russian pro-government
bloggers being a bit more open there
about the damage that the ukraine forces
are doing and really kind of warning and
kind of demanding more in the way of uh
supplies and military focus from russian
leadership to prevent really ukraine
making inroads here is a really
important symbolic target this was the
first major city that russia was able to
take from ukraine right at the beginning
of the war with pretty shambolic
ukrainian defense so if it proves
possible for ukraine to retake the city
that really will be assigned to
ukrainians but also to the wider world
that ukraine is able to really push back
this russian tide
talk to us nick about the zaparisia
nuclear plant uh ukraine's president
vladimir zolensky says it's on the verge
of disaster what's going on at that
power plant right now
this is a very very dangerous situation
this is europe's biggest nuclear power
plant one of the biggest worldwide
and one that is on the front lines and
we've seen video and photo images on the
internet that show seem to show russian
military positions russian military kit
on the territory of that nuclear power
station sometimes even within inside the
structures of this power plant now as we
understand only one of the six blocks is
currently operational but there is
shelling going on every day in and
around that plant we saw those
international uh monitors from uh those
outside bodies trying to come in and
trying to get an idea of what's the
situation on the ground they still
haven't released their report in full
but there is a feeling that you know
this is a time bomb and that unless this
power plant is fully shut down this is
something that could really
pose harm not only people in ukraine but
also to most of europe i think it's also
important to remember that it's not just
the danger of a direct hit but even if
the power plant is operational if for
instance the energy supply to the plant
is interrupted for some time that could
affect the cooling and could lead to the
kind of disaster that we saw in
chernobyl so it's not just about direct
hits it's about any kind of interruption
to the work of this power plant that is
exceedingly dangerous to hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people in
this part of europe
nick thank you very much for now our
correspondent nick connolly there in
kiev